on est bien
elle est pourquoi le mot d'amour le plus
content est-ce que c'est merci encore
plus vite ou oui oui
le mot d'amour le plus con way to bons
doigts
puis plus d'un mais qui dit il n'a
aucune chance et ils aiment tous non
parce que j'aime bien j'aime bien que
les choses se fassent dans la peau
rythme non dans un rythme pas forcément
rapide j'aime bien quelque chose se
passe autour voilà on est prévenu alors
imagine maintenant ses suites les
questions qu'on as un jeu j'imagine que
tu es le choix tu sois pendant dix ans
soit privé de boue c'est à dire tu est
nourri par des sondes intraveineuse tu
ne manges pas ou privés de sexe c'est
hier que tu as les mains attachées au
holy peux rien te faire même à toi même
qu'est ce que tu choisis
pas bouffer ça nous gêne pas j'ai pas si
énorme bien que je bien que j'aime bien
la bouffe la bonne bouffe et j'ai peint
très bon appétit et puis chaque sexe ça
ne dérange pas parce que moi je me suis
je j'ai d'autres palliatifs donc
salémata chez sony on est bien d'accord
oui oui bon d'accord
j'ai toujours mes yeux pour voir bon
d'accord c'est contemplatrice plus de
t'être on va les envoyer
et alors imagine soir tu rentre tard le
soir oui
tu te fais agresser
ça peut arriver est ce que tu as fait
plus peur de te faire agresser par david
et johnatan
c'est terrible c'est terrible licence iv
ou des buts
essentiels m'attendais lui des donateurs
ils sont 2 84 et combien
sont deux
écoutes par david et de l'internât les
miches préfère parce que je pense que je
pourrais à user de ruse et de sud a
choisi n'est plus moi les mots en
musique maurice pourrait avoir -6 à
timoko maintenant vont ils t'ont ils
t'ont fermés dans une cape de hln c'est
un jeu wii ta punition préféré ça se
paie l'oreille passé l'âge ou mordu la
fesse piqué david et johnatan toujours
tim jordan alors une passe et de bosses
l'oreille il te mords l'âge où ils te
pique la paix
les joueurs démontrent que par très
fort y un rendez vous à
rosemère symbole alors tu arrive chez
toi bon tuto enfui tu arrive chez toi
hein c'est une sorte de cauchemar
la chose qui ferait le plus peur ce
serait quand ouvre la porte de chez toi
ça serait qu'il ya un rat un fantôme ou
eric charden
américaine récemment
ses parents halimi nations unies entre
eric charden espace cathare des rares
ouais je trouve ça mignon les fantômes
je crois que ça m'exciterait beaucoup
d'avant me sens comme chez moi je crois
que j'aurais plus peur par internet
parce que vraiment je me demandais ce
qu'il faut
alors maintenant tu voyais richard d'un
an rentrant chez toi tu morte de peur ça
te demande
si tu es morte de peur ou de rire puis
tu te réincarne tu crois la
réincarnation
j'essaye bon quand tu te réincarné dans
un objet absolument ridicule un du trac
avant si tu préfères être incarnée dans
le slip de bar de chirac ou de giscard
toute façon
ils doivent pas près de prendre beaucoup
de place
que le slip soirée tranquille tu arrêtes
sénart
on se